[Music]
why can't we do a conversation about how
Hana my knees because she's a fictional
character so there's also the other more
pressing matter how criminally underage
she's played by Emma Watson who is not
underage and totally hot she was
underage when she played Hermione table
read are you waiting for me to say
something well you do have the first
line in the script
oh Wow that okay hey you know what
I was thinking the other day when I was
watching Harry Potter you name one
actress it's hotter than Emma Stone fact
cut whatever Watson not a stone you
don't ask as usual you messed up your
line no I didn't he might know but I
didn't
because it's probably hard to remember
your lines when you don't bother to
learn in the first place I learned them
I do like just forget them all right we
need to define here so you learn lines
you know we do not need to take five and
I got the huggabug says you don't got
this you are not helping all right and
you forgot to put your hood on so think
you have headphones on and you I can
replace you with any number of guys
around here that look like you all right
what are you threatening me like do you
want me to call my agent your dad is not
your agent no matter how many times you
say it you status no man doesn't know
who the hell you are
it's not my fault he can't remember who
I am it's actually entirely your fault
you were the one who'll be the ladder
[Music]
buddy what are you doing I don't know
how you can even complain about me and a
set that also has him on he's just as
much a part of this family as you are
all right who deserves to be a part of
this can you at least give him a job
where he doesn't screw up every take I
mean did he even graduate from
microphone school there's no such thing
as microphone school in this case
there's not even any such thing as
microphone
that's not a microphone it's a golf club
one looks of it it's a three woman buddy
come on we do hope to use him confident
he's not incompetent you just have to
learn how to work with somebody slower
than you I sure did
wait guys how do we even recording audio
right now that's it I'll be in my
trailer
you mean the cool look yes I guess we're
taking time no I don't worry about it
I'll just do both parts how will that
work
no change shirts in between and just
split screen it down the middle who's
gonna know